welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the falcon of the winter
soldier drags front and center in the
mcu
best friend sam wilson and bucky barnes
what's going on in that cyborg brain of
yours
god i am what
you couldn't have done that earlier i
hate you hello girl kick your ass
yikes with friends like these they
definitely don't need the enemies
they're facing together
zemo returning from civil war unworthy
cap's successor us
agent and a new militant group called
the flag smashers
an imminent threat now facing these two
who what and why
are these people these guys use brute
force they're strong
we're gonna need all hands on deck for
whatever's coming next the leader of
this group played by aaron kellerman a
character we think named carly morgan
though
shows off an insanely spring-loaded leap
out of that truck
so super are these humans that sam and
bucky now debate
what they even are i have a feeling they
might be a part of the big three what
big three
androids aliens and wizards that's not a
thing that that's definitely
no it's not every time we fight we fight
one of the three there are no wizards
dr strange is a sorcerer a sorcerer is a
wizard without a hat
look that's not the point these guys
aren't magical all right they use brute
force just like you
i love it the big three of mcu villains
according to sam wilson
androids aliens and wizards androids
probably referring to ultron and his
army of centuries
aliens referring to thanos and his army
wizards is interesting because when is
falcon fought a wizard loki and ebony ma
are sorcerers but
neither have hats and sam never fought
loki and sam definitely would have
sorted squidward into house alien before
house wizard
kaiselius was a threat after sam joined
the avengers but doctor strange seemed
to deal with him exclusively all that
wizard battle stuff seemed to be pretty
isolated in that movie away from the
avengers i bring this up because sam
could be referring to the recent events
of wandavision when
sword agents faced off with a witch
agatha harkness
and scarlet witch which could reflect
sam and other avengers seen
her as a growing threat but these flag
smashers are not
magic according to sam so that leaves
their superhuman abilities more of a
mystery
i doubt they're aliens like cree or
skrull or asgardian
i also doubt they're androids though i
do find it hilarious how sam sees
bucky's vibranium arm as making him an
android with that whole cyborg brain
line
it's worth discussing because
superhumans don't just spring up around
the world in the mcu like this there's
almost always some plot justification
that leads to the movie that they're in
like super tech falling into the wrong
hands and or being applied on test
subjects in some dimly lit lab
so what mystery fourth category could
this group fall into
but before i continue this video is
brought to you by cove audio in their
split
bluetooth speaker the split has a
powerful subwoofer with a really great
sound quality and can operate for up to
seven hours on a single battery charge
but what really sets the split apart is
that it can
split apart when combined together the
two speakers create a surround sound
effect but when separated they create a
left and a right stereo sound
so you get a taste of that home theater
sound even when you're chilling outdoors
or traveling
it connects to smartphones tablets and
computers via bluetooth 4.2
the speaker can be up to 32 feet away
from the mobile device or computer that
they're paired to and play without
interruption
and this cove speaker is water resistant
up to one meter depth
so you can use it around the pool or at
the beach or during your family's annual
squirt gun showdown
the rocking tunes never have to stop
even when aunt ruth super soaks you
she's ruthless so for a discount of 67
off use my link and the code new
rockstars at checkout that's code new
rockstars at checkout using the link in
this video's description the flag
smashers get their name from flag
smasher
carl morgenthau a cat villain in the
comics who believes in doing away with
the whole concept of countries and
nationalism he leads a terrorist network
called ultimatum
to dissolve political divisions and
borders into a common world mindset
i mean take away the terrorism and it's
a fairly noble cause i'm not gonna get
into a political theory debate with you
i'm just saying
world government works great for star
trek so what would lead this group to
adopt such an ideology
my first assumption is the same thing
that bucky and steve rogers went through
super soldier serum steve rogers
received a unique dosage of super
soldier serum a cocktail formulated by
dr erskine erskine defected from johann
schmidt who took a less refined version
of the serum and became red skull
hydra got their hands on another version
of the super soldier serum and used it
for their winter soldier program which
included bucky
it's also worth noting that in the 2008
incredible hulk film
it was explained that bruce banner's
freak incident was actually connected to
thaddeus ross trying to reboot that same
captain america super soldier program
biotech force enhancement yeah super
soldier
down to the tanks from which he
retrieved the serum for blotsky having
the stark industries
and reinstein the alias of erskine on
the label
so this group could be super soldiers
cut from the same cloth as bucky
and cap which could explain one why
they're so disaffected from fighting
under
any flag ever and two how they're able
to kick bucky's ass
hello girl kick your ass
okay okay another explanation for what
category these superhumans could fall
into
is well what other marvel superhuman
groups brings up organically around the
world
mutants i've brought up a lot of ways
mutants could come into the mcu but
right now it seems like the most logical
way forward is that
certain individuals in the population
have always had a genetic predisposition
which could get called a mutant gene or
the x
gene but that only now after avengers in
game is that gene getting
activated in those individuals why now
well i'm hoping we get those answers in
a celestial taught ancient history
lesson in eternals
but like everything with mutants the
simple answer would be
evolution until now humankind hasn't
needed superpowers for survival but with
the new arrival of thanos and other
extraterrestrial threats
human evolution naturally triggers a
biological mutation
to make all earthlings better fit for
survival
the spark could have been the four
bursts of cosmic radiation
unleashed by the infinity stones this
could be what we saw with monica rambo
whose physiology was already weird
before each of those passes through the
hex wall
a history that she seemed to already
know about but was too afraid to talk
about and then the cosmic microwave
background radiation
of the hex wall further enhanced her
into the superhuman she is now
something similar could have happened to
the freaky superhumans of this group
and there could be a lot more people
like them out there so
sam's big three could be about to become
the big four
androids aliens wizards and super
soldiers or mutants let me know what you
think you can also support this channel
by
checking out one of our many great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for everything marvel
thank you for watching and hey thank you
for sticking with me instead of all
those bitter babies who said my wanda
vision theories ruin their lives
as a psycho forever on the mephisto
train
[Music]
you